Das Podcast UFO Projekt. Herzlich willkommen bei der neuen Folge Das Podcast UFO. Mir gegenüber sitzt Stefan Tietze. Was? Er hat nicht mal die Kopfhörer auf, die Hose ist noch offen, die einen Socken hat er an. Lass nochmal anfangen, ruhig. Das ist es jetzt aber. Das war das Intro? Das war das Intro, ja, von Patrick. Ich habe nichts gehört. Patrick hat natürlich in seiner satirischen Musikbegabung mein Mantra, kurz ist gut, gegen mich gewendet, aber ich habe nicht mal gehört, dass es angefangen hat. Er hat mich mit eigenen Waffen geschlagen, er hat mir ein eigenes Süppchen aus meinem Gemüse gerührt. Patrick hält mir den Spiegel des Gorgonen vor und ich erstarre zu Stein und du gleich mit, denn wir brauchen euch am Ende des Tages, wenn die Intros zu kurz sind. Nervig, ey. Weißt du, was ich dachte, was ich dieses Jahr weniger in meinem Leben brauche? Und vielleicht habe ich das schon ein bisschen verraten durch die Anmoderation, aber es sind tatsächlich Gorgonen. Ich dachte auch, dass 2024 endlich mal ein Jahr wird, wo man sich um viele Dinge Sorgen machen muss. Ja, genau. Wir reden heute noch über die Wahl, aber nicht über Gorgonen. Und die Klimakrise und natürlich auch Heizungsprobleme und Bnstoffzellen. Du kannst heutzutage nicht mehr ohne Spiegel aus dem Haus, weil du weißt nicht, wann wieder die nächste Gorgone um die Ecke kommt und du den Spiegel brauchst, um wiederum die zu steinen. Und nur jetzt, um alle reinzuholen, die nicht wissen, was Gorgonen nicht war. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, das sehen wir vor, ich nicht weiss. Also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Vielleicht die Aethepetete, die im vierten Stock wohnen, ja, in der Schlossallee. Okay, die kennen die vielleicht nicht. Die wissen vielleicht nicht, was Gorgonen sind, ja, aber die normalen Leute von der Strasse, die wissen das nur sehr genau. Die wissen das zu, finde ich, zu genau. Viel zu genau, ja. Die Gorgonen sind nämlich Singular Gorgone oder Gorgo oder Georg sind in der griechischen Mythologie drei geflügelte Schreckgestalten mit, das wissen jetzt alle, nun wirklich alle Schlangenhaaren, die jeden, der sie anblickt, zu Stein erstarren lassen. Schlangen können in verschiedenen Frisuren gestylt werden, beliebt ist natürlich der Schlangenschwanz, man packt sie zusammen, Hochsteckfrisuren oder die Dread-Schlange, wo einige unglückliche Schlangen gemeinsam verfilzt werden, zu einer dicken Schlange. Und normalerweise reicht eigentlich so ein Gorgonenhaar nur für zwei dicke Dread-Schlangenhaare. Medusa, hi, lange nicht gesehen, was machen wir heute mit deinen Haaren? Ja, also. Mit deinen Schlangen, was machen wir heute mit deinen Schlangen? Hört jetzt hier. Hört auf jetzt, hört auf. Die sind aber wild. Nein, seid lieb zu dir, seid lieb zu dir, Rebecca. Möchtest du erst mal einen Kaffee? Ja, ich nehme einen Kaffee. Mit Hafermilch oder mit Ermond Drink? Nee, aber warum hat der Emposier da? Ich bin so froh, dass du fragst, wie gerade er ist eingekauft. Ah toll, ja dann machst du mir einen Becher. Ja, natürlich hier. Ja, ich setze mich dann schon mal in den Stuhl. Ein Spiegel! Oh nein, Fred, Fred. Ja, Rebecca, ich bin gerade im Lager. Du weißt genau, der neun Uhr Termin jeden Freitag ist ja. Soll ich rauskommen? Ich verstehe nicht, du hast mit mir gesprochen. Dann erwarte ich, dass du rausgehst aus dem Lager in eine Hörweite kommst. Ja, da bin ich, da bin ich. Hallo Da bin ich, da bin ich. Hallo, du hast schon wieder, guck mal, Medusa ist ganz versteinert. Jetzt ist sie wieder ganz versteinert. Ich habe dir gesagt, der Freitagmorgens neun Uhr Termin, der neun Uhr Termin, der ix Termin, freitags morgens gehört Medusa. Es tut mir leid. Du hast eine Aufgabe, Medusa. Ich sollte die Spiegel abhängen. Was machst du hinten im Lager? Du bist im Lager. Die Ambrosia-Lieferung kam doch rein und ich habe da immer das Alte, habe ich jetzt nochmal oben gestellt und das Frische nach unten, weil da hat noch eine alte Kiste übrig, der sollte weg. Aber ich sollte die Spiegel abhängen, tut mir leid. Du weißt, dass sie kein Trinkgeld gibt. Die wird jetzt langsam wieder normal. Das haben wir schon mal erlebt. Exakt. Und dann kann man die nicht berechnen für die neun Jahre, in denen sie jetzt versteigert ist.
Soll ich die ins Lager packen? Packst du die ins Lager. Packst du den alten Platz. Nee, was ist das? Stell sie vorne ins Atelier, dann kommen vielleicht Kunden, weil das sieht auch cool aus. Ah ja, vielleicht können wir da auch eine Perücke drauf machen oder so. Oder so. Und das, sie sahen Medusa in der Neuintervention.
Sie hörten.
Sie hörten am Stuttgarter Sie fühlten in allen Gliedmassen ihres Körpers. Viele Sinne wurden bespielt, nicht alle, wohlgemerkt. Der Geschmackssinn hatte Pause. Sie fühlten Medusa in einer Interpretation von Florian Willischer-Fatize für die Volksbühne Stuttgart. Wohl eher Medusel, schreibt die Stuttgarter Allgemeine Zeitung.
Ist ja aber eigentlich, das Leben eines Gorgo ist ja in der Moderne relativ schwierig.
Ich stelle mir vor, früher in der Antike, wie viele Spiegel gab es da.
Einen polierten Schild von Herkules, gut, aber ansonsten, wenn du nicht zum Bad gehst.
Erzählt denn spiegelnde Oberflächen wie zum Beispiel das Wasser?
Ja, das ist ja die Frage.
Also das ist natürlich dann auch der Gag, Gorgo im Freibad, ha ha ha, hat ein Bumbum in der Hand, springt vom Dreier und dann sagen die Kinder, nicht runtergucken, Gorgo, spring einfach, die kleine, die junge Gorgo, spring einfach, spring einfach. Und dann schaut sie aber trotzdem runter und wird zu Stein, fällt dann aber runter, macht einen dreifachen Salto als Stein-ingorgo, alle jubeln, währenddessen die Schlangen unter Wasser ersticken. Und dann hat sie leider tote Schlangen. Ach so, ist versteinert, aber hat halt keine Schlangen. Genau. Was will man mehr? Wahrscheinlich Schlangenhaare. Ich finde Schlangenhaare, glaube ich, ziemlich nervig, aber mit den heutigen Trends, man kann sie färben lassen, man kann sie Dauerwelle. Aber einmal im Monat häuten sich die Bi. Aber es gibt ja heute tatsächlich, finde ich, viel zu viele spiegelnde Oberflächen. Ich will mich gar nicht unbedingt sehen. Nee, geht mir genauso im Alltag. Und deswegen hat es jedes Glas reflektierend, überall Schaufenster, jedes Auto verchromt, überall, jeder Löffel ist eine Gefahr für mich. Will ich nicht sehen. Boah, weisst du, was ich so geil fand? Ich war neulich auf so einer, es war eine Geburtstagsparty, aber Geburtstagsparty turned so Orgie. Nee, so Techno-Rave-Orgie. Ah, okay. Und dann die Orgie. Aber erst so ein Techno-Rave auf so einer Baustelle. Plötzlich fand ich mich an so einem Ort, wo ich normalerweise nicht bin. Aber spannend, das war so, ah, okay, das war wie so eine Dokumentation, so eine Shakey Cam-Dokumentation durch meine Augen. Ach so, weil du hier laufen bist? Weil ich gewackelt bin, ja genau, weil ich laufe, ist dann recht schön. Du hattest nicht die Steady Cam dabei, wie sonst? Nee, ich laufe nicht. Manche haben so ein ganz, nicht durchgedrückte Knie wie ich, sondern so, die haben dann so ein Steady Cam, aber ich, wenn ihr durch mich in meine Augen die Welt gucken würdet, wäre es ja bouncy. Ich mag das auch, wenn bei Filmen so Action simuliert wird durch eine Shaky Cam und man sich denkt, wie rennt dieser Mensch? Ja, ja. Rennt wie so ein Muppet. Ja, genau. Man denkt, so hart ist mein Blickwinkel nicht verrüttet, wenn ich renne. Es ist nicht so wild. Und dann sieht man Tom Cruise von vorne und es ist eigentlich alles genau, guckt in die Kamera, Kopf bewegt sich gar nicht. Nenke cam furchtbar es ist wahrscheinlich zu langweilig gewesen als man wirklich mal jemanden hätte rennen lassen ist zu gut jedenfalls war dann da das fand ich ganz toll als raumtrenner es war so eine baustelle da wollte jemand einziehen haben die sich gesagt so lange unsere wohnung unser haus noch eine baustelle ist kann man ja einfach da unseren wilden Rave feiern. Und dann haben die sich überlegt, um Räume abzutrennen, hatten sie noch keine Türen, sondern sie haben sich Vorhänge überlegt. Und irgendwer von denen hat irgendwie was mit Arzt, Medizin und Ermer zu tun, jedenfalls hat er so Panikdecken, diese goldenen Panikdecken. Und die hat er aufgehangen, diese Knisterdinger, hat die aufgehangen, fand ich ein bisschen so weird, unsettling. War also was Dexterhaftes irgendwie, wie so ein Mordlabor irgendwie. Ja, und nun hing das so dann zwischen den Räumen, zwischen den Türen und dann habe ich dann erst mal gecheckt, von der anderen Seite konnte man durchgucken. Moment, also wenn du eingewickelt bist in die Decke, dann kannst du nicht, man kann rausgucken, aber nicht reingucken.
Man kann sich die über den Deckel ziehen und dann die goldene Seite ist reflektieren, da siehst du deine Pfanne, will man nicht, wollen wir gerade, will man nicht, will man nicht sehen. Aber die andere Seite ist extrem wichtig, Shoutout, extrem wichtig, welche Seite, lass sie fallen, würde ich ja gern. Ich habe gesagt, ich will dieses Jahr nichts mit Gorgonen zu tun haben.
Ja, ich weiss.
Und jetzt sind sie überall.
Ja, ich vers dieses Jahr nichts mit Gorgonen zu tun haben.
Ja, ich weiß.
Und jetzt sind sie überall.
Ja, ich versuch's ein bisschen runterzuspielen.
Jedenfalls von der einen Seite kann man komplett durchgucken und ich fand das super faszinierend.
Und dann habe ich mit Leuten darüber gesprochen, niemand hat meine Faszination für diese Panikdecke und diese FBI-Haftigkeit geteilt.
Ich fand das ganz merkwürdig.
Warum Panikdecke? Also Panik, hat die Angst vor dir oder du Angst vor der? Nein, die hilft dir, wenn du Panik hast. Wenn du Panik hast, kommt die Decke. Sie glitzert fröhlich und im Unentschein. Hab keine Angst, mein Kind, es sei denn, du bist eine Gorgonautin. Dann heilt Abstand von der Panikdecke, sie löst gerade bei dir Panik aus. Es heisst nicht Panikdecke, das wird Stefan jetzt klar, deswegen ist dieser Song so wunderbar. Das ist die Decke, sie hilft dir, wenn du Panik hast, ist ein Unfall passiert, kommt sie herbei. Ist dir kalt, macht sie dich dich warm, ist dir warm macht sie dir kalt, sie kann alles tun, für jung und auch für alt, sie schmeckt auch mal gut, wenn du nen Hunger hast, drum hol dir die Decke, egal wie sehr du Gugonen hast. währenddessen schlimme Unfälle im Hintergrund zu diesem Song, weil wir sollten ja eigentlich diese Decke bewerben, der Song hinten im Hintergrund, Laster fährt in ein Fahrrad rein, schlimm in den Sänger von Glass Animals, der deswegen in Köln nicht auftreten kann. Diese ganze Geschichte übrigens schlug grosse Wellen. Richtig, ich wollte schon sagen. Kurz noch um die eine Klammer zuzumachen, weil wir sind jetzt in einem ganz merkwürdigen Zwischenraum. Wir sind jetzt auf irgendeiner Baustelle, nichts ist fertig. Alle Anekdoten hängen gerade so im Aufbau. Deswegen lasst mich gerade sagen, die Panikdecke heisst nicht Panikdecke. Ihr wisst, was ich meine, die, die man bekommt in Paniksituationen. Ich weiss nicht, die Schockdecke habe ich im Hinterkopf, Panikdecke, alles feilt anscheinend. Es ist diese Notdecke, die man umbekommt, diese silberne, goldene von der silbernen Seite ist sie durchsichtbar. Die einen unsichtbar macht. Harrys Tarnummer, unter dem Knall hat, masturbiert wird im Schlafraum von Gryffindor. Ich wollte schon sagen, du klingst wie ein Lügner, weil du immer sagst, ich war da auf so einer, ja, auf so einem Baustellen-Rave und der eine macht was mit Medizin und man denkt so, auf welchen Veranstaltungen bist du, wo du nicht ein Alibi hast, du bist an Orten, wo du nicht mal ein Alibi hast, obwohl du tatsächlich dort warst und es hat mich auch niemand wirklich gesehen, niemand hat wirklich auf meine Witze angesprungen, du bist einfach ein Phantom, als wärst du nicht da gewesen. Nee, nee, ich versuche immer nicht unbedingt die Leute vor die, vor das Mikrofon zu zerren, ich will die nicht unbedingt exposen.
Ach so, du verfälschst es, alles ist nett von dir.
Deswegen verfälsche ich immer hier und da ein bisschen was würde ich dir auch raten wir haben ja dann doch ein paar zuhören zuhörern und sonst stehen die alle auf der baustelle nachher und raven mit ihr weiss auch nicht wen ich da schützen wollte ich dachte vielleicht kommen noch andere geschichten die heikel werden bei mir, ich benutze Klarnamen, dafür sind die Storys inhaltlich komplett gelogen.
Kommen wir jetzt also zu unserer beliebten Rubrik der Podcast-Ufo-Lüge.
Ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba dingeli dingeli ling, die das Podcast Ufo Lüge, Üge, Üge, Üge, Rüge, Rüge, Rüge, Rüge, Rüge, Rüge, Rüge, Rüge, Rüge auch, denn ich habe vor einigen Folgen eine Geschichte erzählt, wo ich einmal in meinem Leben auf einem Konzert war und ich dachte, ich hätte etwas Cooles erlebt und zwar, ich war auf einem Glass Animals Konzert. Wie muss man sich das eigentlich vorstellen? Wie tanzt du auf so einem Konzert? Ich versuche mich der Masse anzupassen, ich bin wie so eine Alge, die unter Wasser so mit allen im Gleichschritt sich so bewegt. Ich bin phantom, ich bin phantom, mir darf meine Gags nicht reagieren. Das ist mein erstes Konzert, da hat man noch keine Identität so, da ist man einfach da vor Ort und saugt das Erlebnis auf. Oder hat man nicht gerade da die grösste Identität? Nein, Glass Animals hat gespielt in Köln, ich war im Konzert und ich war ein bisschen enttäuscht, weil der Sänger gesagt hat, ich habe mir das Bein gebrochen, weil wir gestern in Dublin so die Bude abgerissen haben. So weit Floritis Lügengeschichte. So stellt sich raus, war von vorne bis hinten komplett gelogen, was mich natürlich in die Situation bringt, alle Geschichten anzuzweifeln, die ich jemals erzählt und auch selber erinnert habe, weil ich erinnere die ja so, aber mein Gehirn sagt einfach, komm, lass uns da mal, lass uns da mal hunderttausend Euro draus machen, nicht zwanzig, lass uns das mal direkt nächsten Tag machen und nicht davor, denn Fakt, jetzt geht's los, Fakt war, der Sänger hat nämlich im Reddit unser Journalismus Bluthund Icaro unterstrich 55 Grimmepreis pending aufgeklärt. Der Sänger hat sich tatsächlich mal kurz vor einer Show und sie war tatsächlich am 29.04.2017 den Knöchel gebrochen und musste daraufhin einige Wochen im Sitzen performen. Es war jedoch vier Wochen vorher passiert, also lüge faktor eins zu acht und
zwanzig nicht am tag davor sondern vier wochen davor nicht an abend vorher und es war in
santiago chile und nicht in dublin also mein kopf macht aus santiago chile, Dublin und aus vier Wochen ein Tag.
Jetzt muss man aber sagen, dass wir ja die Lüge haben wir ja schon im Podcast exposed.
Ich habe sofort meine Fingerchen angeworfen.
Genau, du hast aber, du hast den Bassisten gefunden, der sich bei einem Rollerunfall in Dublin.
Und jetzt glaube ich, jetzt ist es spannend.
Erstens, was macht ihr als Band? Warum verletzt ihr euch? Du sprichst jetzt direkt an Glass Animals. Ich muss es direkt sagen, jetzt rede ich dir direkt diesen True Crime Podcast, die dann so lächerlich werden, weil sie den Mörder direkt ansprechen. Ja, stell dich. Und das ist jetzt für euch, Glanimals. Glorious Animals. Da haben sich die S auch noch gebrochen oder was? Und das geht jetzt direkt an euch, Glass Animals. Vielleicht solltet ihr euch einen anderen Lifestyle angewöhnen. Weniger verletzen, weniger Fahrrad fahren, ein bisschen mehr auf eure Umwelt achten. Und falls ihr euch doch mal verletzt, dann überprüft mal eure Versicherung, denn da gibt es mittlerweile wirklich tolle Angebote. Da muss niemand viele verschiedene Angebote.
Viele verschiedene Angebote.
Wüsste ich nicht. Aber interessant, weil
ich hatte von dem Bassistenunfall in Dublin noch
nie was gehört, aber irgendwie
hat mein Kopf da Dublin draus gemacht,
obwohl, ich meine, wenn du eine Band hast,
wie viele Leute da sind in so einer Band, 20 Leute,
die werden sich wahrscheinlich, wenn die jetzt über
Jahr, ich meine, das war 2017, vor acht,
vor sieben Jahren, wann nehmen wir die Folge auf, vor zwölf Jahren, vor zwölf Jahren und das heißt ja wahrscheinlich, wenn die jedes Jahr touren, ja mit jeweils, wie sagt man, hundert Auftritten und Auftritten sagt man ja, Gigs, Shows, und dann fährt man durch die Gegend und dann ist ja auch einfach langweilig, du bist in Santiago, Chile, wir kennen das ja auch von unserer Podcast-Live-Tour, man kommt da in Mainz an und hat noch drei Tage Zeit und da denkt man, ja springe ich mal in Fluss oder von einem Hochhaus. Wie war das in Rio de Janeiro? Wir kommen da an, natürlich erst mal Jetlag, so dann haben die Veranstaltungen gesagt, ey, ihr habt morgen die grosse, an der Copacobana die grosse Show, das war die Grösste, ich glaube, da hatten wir 50.000 Zuschauer oder sowas, weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr genau. 50.000 und den Strand halt komplett, es gab noch Steppenwäsche am Strand, es war auch ein R komplett eigentlich, ja. Die wenigsten haben uns verstanden, aber es sind einfach sehr viele gekommen, weil wir halt diese grosse Bühne da aufgebaut haben. Und drüber stand, hört uns an, und das war die Tür, La Podcast, und das heißt halt, es ist halt eine berühmte Beleidigung auf Porto-Riesisch. Das haben wir im Nachhinein erfahren während der Show. Und deswegen waren so viele Leute da. So, und in der Geschichte, der ursprüngliche Termin musste abgesagt, wegen werden Orkan, und dann sitzt er da erstmal im Hotel, ist Orkan, und dann denkst du dir, was ist so ein Orkan, kann ich da jetzt rausgehen, wo bin ich, Santa Domingo, Google, wo bin ich, wer bin ich? Ja, da ist vorhin ein Orkan gegangen, wo nichts passiert ist, aber ich hätte Langeweile im Hotelzimmer mit dem Skateboard rumgefahren, habe mir dabei den Klöchel verletzt. Und das ist halt diese Dinge, die passieren ganz schnell. Langeweile tötet. Deswegen Vorsicht, Freunde, Langeweile tötet. Langeweile tötet langsam und qualvoll. Langeweile ist so perfide.
Nehmt euch ein Magazin mit, die bunte, Emma, mal so wirklich was zum Blättern.
Ja, die bunte oder schwarz-weiss.
Wie ihr möchtet.
Ihr könnt euch die Farben aussuchen, wie ihr das wollt.
Darum ging es mir gar nicht. Mir ging es nicht um die Farben.
Du hast so getont hast.
Mir ging es um, nee, Farben hin oder her, was zum Fühlen, welche Sinne ihr ansprecht, mir egal.
Hauptsache, ihr lenkt euch ab.
Langeweile, man ist dann auf dem Skateboard, man steht auf einem Ball.
Ich habe jetzt so einen Gymnastikball mir zugelegt und ich habe den aufgepumpt und in meinen Augen gingen schon so die Top 50 Verletzungen, die man sich mit diesem Gymnastikball zufügen kann. Erstmal natürlich, du setzt dich drauf und du versuchst natürlich so hoch zu springen, wie es geht. Und natürlich von meinen inneren Augen einfach direkt geplatzt unter mir. Ich falle, der Steiss voraus, Steiss voraus, Steiss gebrochen, Steiss kaputt. Es geht ein Riss einmal durch meinen kompletten Körper, alle Knochen gebrochen, ich klappe, klaffe auseinander wie eine Melone. Glass bones. Glass bones und dann ist erst mal zu Ende. Ansonsten habe ich natürlich auch den zweiten Move gemacht, ich habe mich mit dem Bauch auf den Ball gelegt und so nach vorne und zurück. Wo man immer diese Videos, die man aus Upsi-Pan-Show kennt oder von TikTok, so The Daily Dose of Internet. Ja, nach vorne, dann fällt man links runter, dann fällt man rechts runter, hat Spaß, Spiegel, direkt zack, mit dem Kopf direkt auf den seitlichen Spiegel zu und da warte ich eigentlich nur noch auf eine Verletzung. Das heißt, wenn ich in zwei Wochen hier sitze, mit einem gebrochenen Arm, ihr wisst, wer zu verurteilen ist. Der Ball. Der Ball. Der Ball. So, du hast völlig recht, im Juli 2018, ein Jahr später, hat sich der Drummer, du hast wieder gelogen, Drummer Joe Seward, wir müssen jetzt fakten treu bleiben, was seriously injured when he was hit by a lorry while cycling in Dublin. Also, du hast es falsch in Erinnerung, es kann sein. lorry? Genau. Das ist auch ein englisches Outlet, oder wie? lorry ist, haben wir das letzte Mal herausgefunden, Lkw's. Truck, ja. Genau, lorry ist haben wir letztes mal herausgefunden ja ja ja getroffen genau und dann schwer verletzt ich will nur sagen das war ein jahr später das heißt ich weiß nicht seit wann die geschichte bei dir im kopf ist ein tag vorher war es dublin wenn es bin die geschichte nämlich nach 18 vorm angenommen hat kann schon sein dass dein kopf aus der der Dublin-Information, du bist ja als großer Glass Animals-Fan, schon immer ein Auge drauf. Du bist darauf hingewiesen, wenn was passiert, weißt du, du bist der erste, der es erfährt, wenn Joe Seward etwas passiert. Ich zweifle seitdem total an meinem Gedächtnis, aber auch am Gedächtnis der gesamten Menschheit. Der Nelson Mandela Effekt.
Ne, ne, so sagt man, alle sagen so.
Genau, der Nelson Mandela Effekt.
Oder nicht?
So sagen, da war, also meiner Erinnerung nach, nennt man das. Ja, ich kenne den nur als Nelson Mandela Effekt.
Hat er noch einen zweiten Namen?
Aber ich denke natürlich auch an die gesamte menschliche Geschichte, an Ägypten und was auch immer, wo ich mir denke, wenn allein schon diese sieben Jahre bei mir zu so einem Bullshit geführt haben, woher wollen wir überhaupt eine Aussage, was vor tausend Jahren, was mit Jebus passiert ist, einfach komplettes
Hörensagen Bullshit, tausendmal durch diese
Bullshit-Waschmaschine durchgenudelt?
Eigentlich kann man nichts sagen.
Eigentlich müssten alle Historiker gemeinsam
ihren Schal in die Luft werfen und sagen,
das war's. Wir haben keine fucking Ahnung,
wir haben unzuverlässige Quellen, wir wissen nicht, was los
ist. Steht mal alle Historiker
jetzt mal kurz auf. Ja, okay.
So, man steht mal auf. Um Saal tatsächlich, zwei an der Copacabana, zwei stehen auf. Und jetzt schüttelt euch mal, wenn man diese Schauspielerscheisse anwendet auf so Historiker. So, jetzt macht ihr erstmal den Kopf kreisen lassen, langsam kreisen lassen, vorne runter kippen lassen, mal tief durchatmen und dann mal Arme ganz voll schütteln, Arme ganz voll schütteln und Beine auch und macht mal, einfach mal den ganzen Schmutz mal den ganzen Schmutz rauslassen. Der ganzen Sand der Geschichte, die ganze Sand, alles raus. Alles, was sich so angehäuft hat, so die kleinen Verhärtungen im Kopf. Staub der Archive. Und wenn ihr Wut habt, Rechner ging nicht an, Update hat zu lang geladen, mal rausschreiben, noch schnell. Die Assyra!
So, und jetzt setzt euch wieder an den Laptop und überlegt mal,
ob mit meinen Gedanken,
ob nicht alles, was ihr jemals aufgeschrieben habt,
grober Unfug war.
Ich glaube schon, ich glaube schon.
Man hat auch kein gutes Gedächtnis.
Ich würde behaupten, seitdem man
kontinuierlich aufschreiben kann
oder tapen kann,
ist schon viel passiert. Ich glaube, der Buchdruck war da ein grosser, einfach um Dinge einzuloggen, solange sie noch präsent sind im Kopf. Bei Träumen sagt man ja, schreib sie auf, solange sie noch präsent sind, sonst sind sie Futsch, Futschikato, sagt man. Ja, das sagt man ja. Ja, eben sagt man. Und deswegen meine ich, das hilft schon. Wie viele Träume kann man jetzt noch darüber sprechen, seitdem man aufschreiben kann, was man erlebt hat. Und deswegen, ne? Geschichte ist Zeitverschwendung. Ich meine, ich schaue gerne so Dokus, aber mittlerweile nicht mehr. Ich meine, nicht nur die Erinnerungslücken, sondern auch Übersetzungsfehler. Ist nicht auch irgendwie mit diesem Ding, mit diesem 70 Jungfrauen im Himmel, dass es eigentlich irgendwie 70 Rosinen ist. Eine alte Oma, deine Mutter, deine Oma, deine Oma begrüsst dich mit einer Packung Giotto. Genau, wie zur Hölle funktioniert diese Sprache, dass das der Übersetzungsfehler war. Also wenn wir schon auf dem Niveau sind, Frauen und Rosinen, welche historischen Rosinen können wir dann hinterfragen, umgedreht, was passiert ist in der Geschichte. Deswegen kompletter Nonsens. Ich sage, alles was vor 2007, alles was vor diesem schicksalhaften Tag in der Kölner Music Hall passiert ist, April, nein, 20. April 2017. Ich habe auch eine bekommen. Alles was passiert ist, würde ich mal einfach streichen alles was davor passiert ist egal ja du hast eine mail bekommen du musst sie vorlesen nein das ist werbung es ist einfach wir machen jetzt einfach werbung ja tut mir leid aber es gibt unterschiedliche marketingkonzepte und eins ist es eben podcaster werden sie eine mail zu schicken das ist legitim aber ist es vielleicht auch negative Werbung und dann wird es halt, ist das nicht eine Straftat, wenn wir jetzt ein Unternehmen beschmutzen, was uns nicht gefällt? Nein, wir dürfen über Dinge reden, wenn wir nicht über wollen. Wir dürfen sagen, Toffee-Vee schmeckt wie Schmutz. Good morning, Stefan Tietze. Könntest du schon natürlich einen besseren Schlaf mit Jona genießen? Kundenzufriedenheit ist extrem wichtig, deshalb freuen wir uns, wenn du uns dein Feedback mitteilst und deine Erfahrung mitteilte. Ich habe Spannbettlaken bei Jona bestellt, haben mir nicht gefallen. Farblich nicht, die haben keine Falten geworfen, das muss ich sagen, das war das grösste Problem bei meiner Spannbettlaken-Suche, aber die Farben waren nicht meins, die waren schön verpackt, es war einigermassen schnell, mich hat auch genervt, dass er die dann nicht kostenlos zurücknimmt, sondern man immer Versandkosten privat zahlen muss, das nur von mir, ansonsten, wenn ihr Lust habt auf Podcast-Werbung, in der ich mich dann komplett widersprechen werde und alles ganz toll finde, was ihr macht, freue ich mich sehr auf euren Check. Nächste Folge, heute stellen wir euch vor die Bettlaken von Jona. Sie sind wunderbar, ich habe wundere Hüse und geschlafen. Hört in diese Folge rein, alle haben den Nelson Mandela-Effekt, hören dann in die Folge rein und wir reden nicht mehr darüber. Plötzlich ein harter Schnitt und wir reden erst über Jebus und dann reden wir über Gogo und Again. Die Folge ist auch nur 37 Minuten lang. Der ganze Jona-Part rausgeschmitten. War es raus? Sorry, Jona, ich weiß, ihr seid stolz auf das Produkt, aber sorry, besserer Schlaf wegen eines Bettlaken? Nein, nein, sorry, sorry, die machen mehr. So, die machen mehr. Die machen Spannbetttücher, Relax-Matratzen, Betten, Kissen, Topper, Decken, Zirbe und Textilien allgemein. Die machen schon viel, die sind nicht so schlecht, glaube ich. Es war nicht das, was ich gesucht habe, aber viel Erfolg auf eurem weiteren beruflichen Werdegang. Wir freuen uns sicherlich auf die Quartalszahlen für Scooterei 2024. Ich hatte tatsächlich letztens auch einen Bettlakenvorfall, wo ich gemerkt habe, ich habe Löcher in meinem Bettlaken. Ein BVF? BVF habe ich tatsächlich erlitten, BVS Klasse 1 nur. Und deswegen dachte ich, okay, Bettlakenloch, okay, wo? Wo auf dem Bettlaken? Also das BLL war, wo genau, wenn du jetzt... BLL ist Sektor 1. So, und die Frage ist natürlich ... Von links oder oben rechts? Wenn du jetzt ... Also ich gebe dir jetzt so ein Rechteck. Und du musst mir sagen, wo ist das Loch auf dem Bettlaken? Wo würdest du das Loch vermuten? Wo würdest du das Loch vermuten? Meine waren beide in der Mitte. Genau, wegen des Hüftschwungs. Auf der Seite, auf der ich schlafe. Wegen des nächtlichen Hüftschwungs. Genau. Weil man natürlich, ich träume oft von Tanzveranstaltungen im weitesten Sinne, Tanzcafes. Ja, manche knirschen mit den Zähnen, ich habe so einen nächtlichen Hüftschwung. So Busy Hips, Hips don't lie. So twerking nachts. Und das dachte ich eigentlich auch, aber stimmt nicht, bei mir auf Fusshöhe. Dann dachte ich mir, deine Ekelnägel. Bin ich ein Strampler? Nein, deine Ekelnägel zerren das Bettlaken auseinander. Habe ich lange Zehennägel? Nee, aber vielleicht scharf. Da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht. Ich habe überlegt, bin ich ein Strampler? Strample ich nachts. Man weiss es ja nicht, aber ich darf. Du bist kein Strampler. Okay, da bin ich jetzt erst mal beruhigt. Ich habe die Woche überlegt, ich habe gelebt, als sei ich ein Strampler. Und ich habe überlegt, wo strampele ich hin, wo will ich hin nachts? Du hast schon überlegt, wie sagst du meinen Eltern, dass ich ein Strampler bin? Was sind das für enorme Kräfte, die nachts entfaltet werden, die mich wie so ein Motorboot nach vorne schieben eigentlich. Wird es immer verrutscht. Es ist wirklich oft verrutscht, aber du sagst, meine ja, es ist vielleicht ein, es ist das Feedback-System der Welt, das dir über Umwege sagt, deine Zehennägel sind. Ich habe kein gutes Verhältnis zu meinen Zehennägeln. Zumal mein Problem ist, ich hatte mal einen eingewachsenen Zeh, als ich in Berlin wohnte, in einer WG mit Lars-Erik Powelson. Da habe ich dem natürlich von meinem... Mehr Details, mehr Details. Ich liebe alle Details, die keine Rolle spielen werden. Und dann bin ich natürlich mit meinem Leiden zu meinem Mitbewohner gegangen. Ist ja klar, medizinische Ersthilfe. Wenn ich jetzt wüsste, wie der heißt. Es ist natürlich, du gehst natürlich und sagst, hallo, ich habe zwar keinen Termin, kann ich kurz reinkommen? Hallo, ich bin gerade im Bewerbungsgespräch. Ich habe gerade einen Zoom-Gespräch. Ich habe gerade einen Zoom-Gespräch. Ich habe gerade einen Zoom-Gespräch. Ich glaube, ich habe einen Eingewachsenen ziehen. Guck mal, warte mal, guck mal hier. Sir, yes, Harvard is the biggest dream. We have only one place left, Guy. It's my biggest dream and I would laugh. We have only one place left and we are interested in you? Yes, but my roommate just came in and he says... No, but we need to make the talk now, right? I know, I know. Fuck, geh mal ganz kurz raus. Ganz kurz raus. Aber nur ganz kurz, weil die haben noch einen Platz bei Harald. Schau mal, hier, das ist hier alles voll eitrig. Wir haben einen Platz, so läuft das jetzt. Das ist alles reinge... Ich meine, wie kommt das da wieder raus? Kannst du mir kurz die Füsse halten, kannst du mir... No, this is, the gap is closing, Guy. No, you You wear four, five, three, two, one and over. It's out, it's out. No, you're out. You're out, it's out, you're too late, you're too late, see you later, not. So, und dann bin ich natürlich zu meinem Mitwohner gegangen und der hat gesagt, pass auf, ich weiss sogar, was hier passiert,
denn er ist medizinisch sehr bewandert, ohne Erklärung,
und zwar meint er, das Problem ist, man schneidet die Zehennägel falsch,
weil die meisten Leute denken, Zehennagel, das ist so ein bisschen wie ein Fingernagel in gross.
Völlig falsch, also völlig, völlig am Thema vorbei.
Nagel ist Nagel.
Stefan, ich sehe, du bist auch noch in diesem Tal der Unwissenheit.
Ich werfe dir gerne ein Seil runter.
Ich bin noch am Schlafen noch.
Denn stellt sich raus, wenn du dir die Fingernägel anschaust und du denkst an diesen Klipper.
Wie sieht die Klinge aus?
Rund, halb rund.
Halb rund, weil du natürlich der Fingerkuppe entlang.
Allerdings die Zehennägel auf gar keinen fall rund schneiden sondern gerade wer macht das denn ja ich verstehe ich wundere mich jetzt warum nicht alle in den bettlaken so fünf so gozilla artige riss das finde ich so eklig. Wer macht das denn gerade?
Man soll das eigentlich gerade schneiden, weil sonst läufst du die Gefahr, dass das Nagelbett zu weit reingeht und dann wächst der rein. Ich will lieber 20 eingewachsene Zähennägel und runde Zähn geschnittenen Zähennägel als die verkackte Idee, das gerade abzuschneiden. Und dann hast du dann rechts und links diese weisse. Es steht ein bisschen über, ja. Weil natürlich der Finger, es ist so ein bisschen das Pizzakarton-Pizza-Problem. Du denkst, warum hat er eine andere Form als die Pizza? So ist es ja beim Nagel auch. Der Nagel ist dann gerade, aber der Finger ist rund. Warum? Aber es ist anscheinend gesünder und deswegen ist natürlich immer das Problem, ja, wie schneide ich denn dann die Zehennägel? Weil dann hast du so einen Klipper, aber das geht nicht, weil es ist einfach immer schon, die Klingel ist immer rund und so eine Schere, es gibt nicht das richtige Werkzeug dafür. Und deswegen, um es zu schliessen, ganz kurz die Klingel zu schliessen, und deswegen schneide ich mir die Zehennägel nicht. Gar nicht. Weil ich immer in der Verlegenheit bin, mache ich das richtig, mache ich das falsch, ich will nicht wieder diesen Zehennagel einwachsen, super nervig.
Lass dir als jemand, der noch nie einen eingewachsenen Zehennagel hatte, sagen, man kann sich die runde schneiden.
Das spielt auch die Gene jetzt eine Rolle. Stefan, deine Gene sind Public Domain, dein Genpool ist Public Domain, wir können alle jetzt recherchieren, www.stephan.de, können wir alle dein Genmaterial angucken und sehen, aha, sieh an, er hat nicht das Einwachsgen.
Da hast du natürlich ein Privileg. Nein, ich möchte nochmal auf den Anf, da ist mir nicht was aufgefallen, eine kleine Inkoherenz in der Geschichte. Ach Gott, ich schade wieder, Reddit glüht. fing dann nämlich, kam der Satz, las er die Pausen, mein Mitbewohner, medizinisch sehr bewandert. Warum weiss niemand? So, ein bisschen paraphrasiert. Vielleicht ist da das Problem. Du vertraust jetzt dein ganzes Wissen jemandem an, es kommt von jemandem, von dem du zwar annimmst, er habe medizinisches Wissen, aber die Bestätigung, den empirischen Beweis hast du nicht bekommen. Nein, habe ich nicht bekommen. Vielleicht ist dann da einfach das Problem. Ja, aber er war so selbstbewusst. Ich meine, das muss ja irgendwo herkommen. Ja, ja, ich verstehe das. Ich meine, ich kenne ja mich. Wenn ich es nicht weiss, dann halte ich meinen Mund. Und dann, ausser es geht jetzt um private Fakten, die ich ein bisschen verschönere oder lüge im Hintergrund. Okay, gut, ja, ich bin der Lügner, ich bin für die heutige Folge der Lügner, ich nehme diese Sünde gerne auf mich, okay. Aber ansonsten bin ich still. Aber er ist so selbstbewusst. Ja, ich kenne das gut. Leute, die selbstbewusst sind, haben die Macht, einem Dinge zu verklickern. Das ist ja diese Momente, wo man sagt, wir wetten gleich darum, weil ich bin mir sicher, dass Santiago die Hauptstadt von Chile ist. Und dann kommt halt irgendwann dieses, hat er dem vielleicht doch recht und liege ich falsch. Und das sind Menschen, die selbstbewusst den Punkt drüber bringen können. Ich weiß nicht, wie das kann, manchmal habe ich das auch, aber sehr spannend, die dann auf dem falschen Fuß zu erwischen, auf dem Eingewachsenen Zehnagel zu erwischen, weil dann müssen die nämlich zurückrudern. Und das ist bei Leuten, die das so selbstbewusst wie LEP vortragen, natürlich sehr, sehr schwierig. Aber solche Leute braucht es halt auch, die halt mal sagen, die eine Position haben, so bei der Wahl oder so. Ich habe ja den mitbefolgten Wahlkampf, auch Lokal, so Europawahl, weil auch Lokalwahl oft viel. Und dann hast du halt mal irgendwie so einen Politiker vor dem Edeka stehen, der dir die Hand schüttelt und sagt, ja, mein Name ist Ruben irgendwas, wähl mich. Ruben irgendwas, du, dass du diesen sehr seltenen Namen genommen hast. Jetzt kugeln alle Hamburg Ruben, gibt einen Politiker von der FDP, der vor der, von Rewe ein Spittel stand. Ja, und dann habe ich den auch gewählt. So ist ja klar. Warum? Weil ich ihn sehen gar nicht bei mir aber die ich sehen kann sind ja so menschliche die wirchen nicht im bundestag haben du willst ja die ich weiß ja genau wie er dann so auf seinem bundestagstuhl dann da sitzen und so rum wackelt und dann so kann man das auch verstellen so jemanden will ich denn nicht haben der auch aufs Handy guckt und so und dann hat er nicht richtig zugehört und so. Nee, aber dann habe ich tatsächlich den ein paar Mal gesehen und dann waren auch regelmäßig Leute vorm Edeka, die sich mit dem gestritten haben und die halt dann auch aus der zweiten und dritten Reihe. Also es ist ja oft so, entweder ist er ganz alleine oder wenn jemand mit ihm redet, dann formt sich sofort eine Traube dahinter. Wie bei so einemhlender Künstler. Weil es gibt Leute, die können nur kommunizieren aus zweiter Reihe.
Nur mit so einem ja, verstehe ich. So, die können nicht face to face, sondern die brauchen sowieso einen Sperrkämpfer, der mit seinem langen Sperr über den anderen hinwegsticht.
Die feigsten Kämpfer. Genau, aber die haben halt nur diese Waffe, die können halt nicht anders. Und dann habe ich die auch gesehen, wie die so,
ich dachte mir so, wow, du brauchst schon eine Menge Selbstbewusstsein in deiner Meinung, um mit dieser Energie jemanden wirklich direkt anzugehen. Dessen Job ist es. Deswegen sage ich ja nicht, dass der richtig liegt. Ich sage nur einfach, wie würde das bei mir aussehen, wenn ich, ja, sollten Sie es ja überlegen, also ich habe die Studie, ich habe jetzt keine Studienfachlagelage ich habe die Studienfachlage jetzt nicht da aber ich finde sie können sie also deutschland ging es noch nie so schlecht ich habe die ich habe jetzt keine Quelle ich habe jetzt die Dokumente das Gefühl es war ich habe da mal in der Talkshow was gehört die Lautstärke mit der du sprichst muss sich mit der Fakten muss sich mit einer Fakten also belegten Zitaten decken. Das ist eine lineare Kurve. Du musst, je weniger Fakten, desto leiser musst du sein. Du kannst nicht sagen, ich hab da jetzt keine Fakten zu, ich find so scheiße, ich hab in der Tat schon was gehört, und da man drei Prozent weniger Einkommen für die Oberen, die Oberen, die Ober habe für die oberen die oberen über einen artikel in dem wohlstand haben gorgonen laufen 50 prozent auf der mittelmeerroute des einkommens haben ein prozent ja lautstärke tone it down ja je vager je vager man ist desto leiser hat man zu sprechen. Da muss ich ihn die erste Reihe stellen und dann so. Ich traue ihn nicht. Dann kann ich mit ihm überhaupt nicht reden. Aber es ist ja dieser. Sie sind mir zu wirtschaftsliberal. Glaube ich. Oder libertär. Ah, ich gehe nach Hause. Ich gehe nach Hause. Ich gehe nach Hause. In wem irgendwas. Da mache ich den Wahlomaten. Ah ja. Und ich mache den Wahlomaten immer auf gleiche Weise. Ich drücke immer neutral. Nicht, weil das meine tatsächliche politische Meinung ist, sondern weil ich mir überlege, welche Partei kommt am Ende raus, die sagt neutral. Und diesmal war es die Partei für schulmedizinische Verjüngungsforschung. Ja. Und da dachte ich mir, okay, das ist schon mal ein Versprechen. Aber das ist für mich die unneutralste Partei des Wahlkampfs. Ja, die sagen ja, Jung ist besser als alt. Ja, aber das ist ja ein irres Statement. Das ist ein irres Statement. Das kam nur in Wallomaten nicht vor. Richtig. Also da ist der Wallomaten ja biased. Das ist eine Fragestellungs-Bias. Wenn nämlich der Wallomat die einundzwanzigste Frage hätte, wären sie gern tausend Jahre alt, würden sie gern tausend Jahre alt werden und dann würdest du neutral anklicken, dann wäre die nämlich nicht rausgekommen. Richtig, dann hätte der Wahl-O-Mat ein fucking Problem und würde sagen, scheisse, scheisse, scheisse, irgendwas, irgendwas, aber so ist es auch Ding.
Verstehe das schon, wenn du die Bienenpartei gründest und dann fragt der Wahl-O-Mat halt leider keine Bienenthemen ab, dann bist du völlig am Boden zerstört. Dann ist ja, was willst du machen? Aber ja, das ist schwierig. Also ganz ehrlich muss ich sagen, dieses, ich verstehe dieses Links-Rechts-Spektrum nicht mehr unbedingt. Und zwar ist mir zum ersten Mal jetzt neulich aufgefallen, wo darüber diskutiert wurde, in Österreich, in Wien, darüber, ob man das Alter, in dem man straffällig werden kann, runtersetzen soll. Okay. Von, ich glaube, da sind es auch 14, wie hier ja auch, auf zehn. Okay. Und dann waren sich die Linken alle einig, nein, nein, nein, nein, und die Rechten wollten, fand es auch nicht toll, ab zehn Jahre im Knast zu kommen, theoretisch. Auf diese Idee war es denn dann überhaupt, wenn beide Seiten sagen, eigentlich ist es keine gute Idee. Es gab jetzt keine so eine radikalere Rechte dabei, aber es war so, die Mitte war dann, also die Rechte war eher dafür und die Linke eher dagegen. Und da habe ich nicht verstanden, also warum ist das jetzt eine per se, warum sind sich da alle verschiedenen linken Parteien. Warum bleiben die trotzdem in ihren Gruppen? Genau. Warum sagen nicht die Hälfte der Linken ja und so? Warum ist es, ja es scheint irgendwas zu sein, dass sich die Meinungen auf diese beiden Seiten verteilen oder so, das ist schon, aber zehn, also ein vier Jahressprung, ich meine vier Jahre sind eine Menge in dem Alter, da tut sich viel in der Entwicklung. Ja, und dann kam raus in der Schweiz, ist es nämlich schon so, da könnte die Rüdisch-Zenjährige vor Gericht landen. Aber wer will, dass Kinder ... Also wo kommt dieser Impuls her zu sagen? Dieser Hass, ich verstehe es. In der Einsbruchung, mehr Kinder im Gefängnis. Hast du schon mal einmal neben einem Kind gesessen im Flugzeug? Ich will gar nicht polemisieren jetzt. Ich habe keine Ahnung von dem Thema, ich bin weder dafür noch dagegen, ich bin neutral. Steckt sie alle in den Knast, aber steht sie alle in den Knast. Aber es müssen schon mehr Kinder in den Knast. Ja, auf jeden Fall. So viele Kinder da draußen. Naja, gut. Kitaplätze? Ja Ja, das ist ein Thema. Das ist ein Thema. Ich fände es so spannend, weil das plötzlich so eine sehr klare linke Position anscheinend zu sein hat. Gut, es ist ja eher eine progressive, also vielleicht Denkweise, deswegen verstehe ich schon. Dass Kinder auch Verantwortung tragen? Nee, generell Menschen zu sozialisieren, also eher wieder zu reintegrieren, weniger harte Gefängnisse sozialisieren. Und dazu gehört vielleicht auch in dem Zuge, man geht nicht damit runter. Vielleicht erhöhen? Aber ich finde es nicht so, ich fand es nicht mehr so klar. Ja. Ist krass, dass irgendjemand mal so eine Zahl festlegt, 14, und dann muss sich jeder erklären, der diese Zahl verändern will. Ich liebe das, konkrete Dinge. Das ist so super konkret. Ich liebe konkrete Zahlen. Und dann kann man sich dran reiben. Weil vorher ist, ich finde die meisten Diskurse, auch beruflicher Natur, aber vielleicht auch unsere Kackbranche, aber diese abstrakten Diskussionen über nichts, statt dass man einfach, sobald man mal was schwarz auf weiss hat, kann man sich dran reiben. Das mag ich ja. Das mag ich auch mit dir. Du willst Fakten sehen, du willst Zahlen sehen und dann kann man drüber reden. Aber man bleibt trotzdem, genau, man bleibt automatisch bei geraden Zahlen. Das ist eine sehr interessante Frage. Niemand würde auf die Idee kommen, zu sagen, Leute, wir müssen von 14 auf 11. Da würden alle sagen, was ist hier los? Man hat das Gefühl, dass gerade Zahlen. Ein Gegenbeispiel. Warte mal, Europa war ab 16. Genau. 18, Führerschein 18. Führerschein 18. Schöffen 25, oder? Ne, was war Schöffendienst 25, glaube ich? Weiss ich nicht. Irgendwas? Das kann sein, dass Schöffen 25 ungerade ist. Aber ansonsten, sie, ähm, acht, achtzehn, zwanzig, gibt es irgendwas in Deutschland mit 21? USA natürlich 21. Genau, USA wäre mein Gegenbeispiel gewesen, 21. Ja, aber das war wegen durch drei. Ich dachte durch sieben. Die Glückwunsch zahlt aller. Ja. Nee, bei 21 kann ich mir vorstellen, dass da die Biologie zurande gezogen wurde. Weil man immer sagt, in siebener Abständen oder was? Nee, wenn man sagt, bei 21 ist man aus, ist man fertig, ist Gehirn fertig.
Ach so, okay, okay. Aber warum darf man dann so früh Autofahren? In den USA? Ja. Nicht unbedingt, 18 oder? Ich glaube schon früher. Chef, hast recht, 25, aber das ist ja auch eine gerade Zahl. Guck mal, 25, ich würde auch sagen, 25 ist eine gerade Zahl. Du drückst mein Auge zu. Nee, ich verstehe genau, was du meinst. Weil ich finde, 75 ist auch eine gerade Zahl.
Ja, ja gerade Zahlen. Aber 25 ist gerade als fünf. Fünf ist schief, die ist halb gerade so ein bisschen. Halbbgerade. 25 ist gerade, kommt noch zu den geraden Zahlen. Ja, ja. 75 auch noch zu den geraden Zahlen. Ja, absolut zu den geraden. 1025 ist nicht gerade. Nicht gerade. Nein, ich finde es gut. Ja, finde ich gut, vielleicht können wir da eine Partei gründen, die Partei der Ungeraden. Die Ungeraden. Einfach so, wir haben eine ungerade Anzahl an Mitgliedern, an Abgeordneten und wenn wir eine gerade Anzahl an Stimmen kriegen, lösen wir uns auf, instant. Das ist einfach mal Demokratie als Experiment. Wenn wir eine gerade, und da musst du halt gucken mit deinen Nachbarn, wenn du weißt, dein Nachbar wählt die ungeraden. Überlegst du, wenn ich dir jetzt auch, naja, wie schaffe ich es, die aufzulösen, wo gehen die Stimmen dann hin? Ganz interessant, nur mal Ideen reingeworfen für die nächste Wahl. Nee, ich muss sagen, die Wahl war schlimm und die Ergebnisse waren schlimm, aber Köln war ich sehr stolz drauf. Ja? Ja, Köln hat ganz toll abgestimmt und da habe ich mich, wenn man sich ja schon noch nicht mehr fragt, was mache ich eigentlich hier? Ja, auch so. Das habe ich herausgefunden. M Aber müsstest du nicht sagen, ich werde woanders mehr gebraucht? Ich habe London, ja, stimmt, aber ich habe London besucht und in diesem Zuge mal geguckt, weil das ist ja das Klischee, da laufen immer alle mit Regenschirmen rum, London regnet es immer. Dann habe ich aber gefunden, Köln hat mehr Regentage im Jahr als London. Köln hat sogar mit am meisten Regentage im Jahr in ganz Europa. Und das sind so Momente, wo man denkt, du wohnst vor allem in Hamburg. Hamburg ist regenreicher als Köln. Das habe ich lange gebraucht, bis ich diesen Knurren im Kopf lösen konnte. Ich schätze, Köln hat mehr Regentage, also auch Tage, in denen es fizzelt, werden es Regentage gewählt. Ach so, so ein bisschen nisselt. Da müsst ihr mir mal helfen, wenn da Meteorologen unter euch sind, Meteorologen, helft uns da gerne mal. Ich bin da nicht weitergekommen. Ab wann ist Regen Regen? Ab wann ist Regen Regen und ab wann ist Regen Regentag? Ja, ja, ab wann ist nur so feuchtes Genösel. Weil ich jetzt als Kölner hätte ein Interesse daraus, dass der Regen des Regentags Eintrittsmomentum hochgesetzt wird, weil wenn es jemand nieselt, ist kein Regentag. Wir Kölner würden nicht sagen, das sind Regentag. Das ist doch kein Regentag. Sagst du immer, du brauchst eine Regen für den Regenbogen. Na, in Sülzen-Palli, da ist hinuntergekommen, aber es ist noch kein Regenbogen. Ohne Regen hast du keine Regenbogen, sag ich immer. Ohne Regen, keine Regenbogen, und wenn er hierhinört, wenn er irgendwo hingehört, dann nach Köln.
Man wird immer tiefer, drei Oktarien tiefer, wenn man in Köln spricht.
Ähnlich wie Französisch.
Aber da hilft mir immer, und da habe ich gesagt, warum will ich hier in Köln sein? Und jetzt die Wahlahl so furchtbar die auch war köln hat toll
abgestimmt schön köln ist wirklich eine hochburg für gute leute jetzt mal genug mit politik du Fussball, mein Stern am Himmel leuchtet nur für mich. Mein Bein schiesst eure Tore und vielleicht auch eins für dich, die anderen fahren zum Mondschein, nach Hause Geht's erst morgen! Heute wird der Südfallerel und morgen geht's nach Haus. Bin ich ein bisschen im Dribbelmodus? Ich dribble ... Dribbel ich ein bisschen durch mein Zimmer, ehrlich gesagt. Und ich würde ja gerne ein Grossballturnier starten, wo man Fussball spielt, aber mit riesengroßen Bällen. Ja, aber Profis? Profis? Äh, ja, ja, ruf mal an, wer sind denn deine Top-Profis aktuell? Wemlinger?
Thierry Henry, wer sind die Besitern?
Ruf den mal jetzt an, ruf den doch mal jetzt an.
Meine Top-Fussballer gerade sind, ich mag Florian Wirz sehr gern, dem drücke ich alle Daumen für die EM, ich mag den Musiala sehr gern, dem drücke ich alle Daumen für die EM, Ich meine, dem Tanta sehr gern, dem drücke ich alle Daumen für die EM. Erst im Haus, erst im Haus! Okay. Und den mag ich noch, ach den Kai Havertz, den finde ich auch toll. Ich verstecke, ich verstecke mich. Schatz, Schatz, ich nehme mir gerade diesen TikTok-Trend auf, wo ich die Fussballer aufzähle. Achso, Entschuldigung, ich bin kurz, ich muss wohl eingenickt sein. Du redest im Schlaf, sie sind im Haus. Kurze Frage, Schatz, bin ich ein Strampler? Ja, du strampelst die Bedecke kaputt mit deinen langen Ekelfingernägeln. Das tut mir leid. Wir kriegen die Wohnungstür nicht mehr zu. Weil meine Fingernägel so lange sind. Weil die Fussnägel da dazwischen hängen. Wie so ein Clown, der so ganz lange Beine, deswegen muss ich immer so lange Schuhe tragen. Die Leute denken, ich sei Clown, bin ich nicht. Ich hasse Clowns, ich hasse Humor, ich hasse Witzalbernes. Ich bin, ja, ich habe Clown. Ja, richtig. Ja, widerlich. Die Dreh, die, die, ich hatte ja lange als Kind ein Buchuch das guinness buch der wetterrekorde rekorde und da war natürlich drin längst ein fingernägel und da gab es dann einen der hatte lange fingernägel aber an manche haben sich so wie eine große schnecke ja eingewickelt ich hätte nur ein buch nämlich den strowelpeter und ich finde gut dass wir das gleichissen mitgenommen haben. Denn wenn man die ganze Zeit in die Luft guckt, stirbt man.
Ja, steht wahrscheinlich auch im Guinness Buch.
Die meisten Menschen gestorben durch Luftguck, Hans guckt in die Luft.
Und da gibt es natürlich das berühmte Bild, wie seine Fingernägel wachsen.
Und ich meine, die rollen sich auch ein bisschen ein.
Unglaublich, unglaublich das Leben.
Und dann gab es einen grossen Skandal, weil da gab es ein grosses Räucherkerzenunglück. Oh Gott im Himmel. Aber da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen ausholen, das dauert jetzt ein paar Minuten. Das ist eine riesige Räucherkerzenfabrik, ist in Flammen aufgegangen. Und dann roch Süddeutschland gut. Und dann roch für drei Tage die gesamte Welt nach Zimt. Ah. Weil das hatte eine solche enorme Riechkraft, dass man wirklich wie bei so einem nuklearen Pilz verfolgen konnte. Ich finde es übrigens keine schlechte Kriegsführung. Stell dir mal vor, eine Geruchswelle. Ja, und dann war ich mit der Mareike beim Friseur und dann brrrr.
Sag mal, riechst du das? Riechst du das? Ich glaube, ohne Scheiss, das ist keine eklige Kriegsführung, aber ich glaube, die ist nicht sehr ineffektiv. Geruch ist ein Thema. Wenn du eine Geruchsbombe zündest und es riecht so nach Furz oder so. In ganz Deutschland die Russen zünden eine Furzbombe, so eine Furzbombe. Und Furzkissen. Quasi. Das Zar Furzkissen. Das Geräusch macht die Peinlichkeit aus. Da liegt die Kriegsführung in der Peinlichkeit. wogegen die Kriegsführung jetzt ... Wenn Joe Biden sich hinsetzt und der KGB hat es geschafft, tatsächlich über einen Agenten ein Furzkissen zu platzieren. Auf dem Sessel des Weißen Hauses. Richtig, dann gibt es eine blische Instabilität, die vielleicht zum Kollaps des Militärs führt. Kapitol wird gestürmt, unser Präsident ist zu peinlich, unser Präsident ist zu peinlich, peinlen, peinlen, peinlen, peinspunkt, Punkt eins, Unsichtbarkeit. Bei einem pufft so was, verpufft was und dann eine Zauberfliege. Agent Smith, das ist erst Tagespunkt acht. Ich stehe hinter Ihnen. Setz nicht hin. Punkt eins, Unsichtbarkeit, hat jemand eine Idee? Können wir unsichtbar werden? Ja, Mr. Sullivan? So eine Art Chamäleonanzug, den man so komplett anzieht. Wollen Sie viele Chamäleons oder ein Chamäleonanzug aus der Haut gewonnen? Ach so, das war, ja,äleons heute, ja, oder vielleicht leben die Chamäleon noch. Okay. Also man packt die Chamäleons, packt sie aneinander. Sie wirken, als würden sie sich das gerade ausdenken. Ein Chamäleon muss ja Stellen am Körper haben, wo es nichts spürt. Chamäleon wird ja nicht überall was spüren, oder? Weiß ich nicht. So wie Hunde, die halt am Nacken, die man so am Nacken packt. Das klingt sehr gefühlig. Ne, aber ich meine nur, dass man lebende Chamäleons aneinander näht, ohne dass sie schreien. Wenn die schreien, dann fliegt alles auf. Naja, man ist zumindest unsichtbar. Stefan, doch jetzt! Das ist der zweite Smiley, das ist der zweite traurige Smiley, den du in diese Folge kriegst. Nein. Doch, doch. Nein. Bei zehn fliegst du raus aus der Aufnahme. Nein. Das ist der zweite traurige Smiley für heute. Wann musst du nicht meine Eltern anrufen? So, lies vor. Durch diese neue Regel, die ich aufgestellt habe, mit dem Vorlesen. Musst du jetzt Liebesbriefe vorlesen. Lieber Stefan, dein Geruch ... Nee, aber habe ich jetzt vergessen, das auszumachen.
Dein Geruch hängt immer noch an meinem Bettlaken.
Kann die letzte Nacht nicht vergessen.
Das ist ein bisschen ... gibt Leuten eine Einsicht, wo das Projekt ...
Wie du mich gekitzelt hast.
Das war himmlisch.
Diese Mail ist sehr offenbar, wo es mit dem Podcast rupostet.
Hallo Stefan, suchst du ein bezahlbares Büro in Ehrenfeld? Dann haben wir ab dem ersten Dachten das richtige Büro für dich.
So, und der CIA hat auf jeden Fall überlegt, wie kriegen wir magische Tinte hin.
Ja, und dann kam sie nach einem wahrscheinlich relativ, ja, aktiven Brainstorming,
sagen wir mal,
zum Ergebnis Sperma.
Sperma. Sperma.
Samenflüssigkeit. Ejakulat.
Ejakulat, Prostata,
Penis,
Welt.
Pimmelsaft.
Genau. Lust.
Lustsaft. Genau. Fickmilch. Wie Männersahne. Genau. Und die scheint sich auch ganz gut einsetzen zu lassen als magische Tinte. Die dann, man kennt ja diesen Gag, dass dieses Schwarzlicht angemacht wird, haha, überall Sperma fängt und so. Und die Idee war, wenn man das schreibt, kann man... was leuchtet dem Sperma, was unter Schwarz ist der Kenbeiss? Die weissen Eiweisspartikel. Keine Ahnung. Ja, dann nimm was anderes. Und dann, das ist so, das ist so, diese Story, das ist eine dieser Anekdoten, haben die dann selber verändert, dann haben wir rausgefunden, das ist Sperma. So, und dann haben die sich gesagt, ähm, lassen wir es mal ausprobieren, Feldversuch, mit Sperma zu schreiben den ganzen Tag, können ja viele Agenten selbst zur Verfügung stellen. Und das wurde tatsächlich abgebrochen, wegen des Geruchs. Das habe ich jetzt mal erzählt, dass ich einen Test gemacht habe, einen Fruchtbarkeitstest, und dann stand da drin die Anzahl, bla bla bla, und dann stand auch drin Geruch, Doppelpunkt, normal. Und da ist ja, glaube ich, keine Maschinen gibt, die synthetische Gerüche erkennen kann. Wobei, das ist ja das schlimmste Job der ganzen weiten Welt, ist der Spermaschnüffler. Da muss ja jemand meinen Becher, mit dem ich durch Ehrenfeld geradelt bin, den man in der Hosentasche haben soll.
Ach, du dürftest zu Hause die Probe geben, oder was? Zu Hause durfte man die Probe geben. Ach, das ist gar nicht so wie, ah, Pastewka, Knallerfrau und Sketch, Dinge, die nur so sind, damit Sketche geschrieben werden. Nee, das ist nicht, man kann zu Hause machen, was man will, und dann muss man mit diesem, wie mit einem Neugeborenen, weil man will das nicht schütteln, man will, es geht ja sehr fürsorglich mit um. Ja, damit die Kohlensäure nicht rausgeht. In der nächsten halben Stunde soll man dann zum Arzt das abgeben im Labor. So lange leben die? Die leben noch länger, aber ich glaube, da sind noch gut zu erkennen. Was für ein wissender Satz. Die leben noch länger.
Die leben noch länger.
Wie lange leben die denn?
Das ist nämlich die sehr, dass jemand kann, also kommt mal rein, im Chlor, jetzt im Schwimmbad, da ist ja die Frage, können Frauen schwanger werden im Schwimmbad? Nee, nicht unbedingt, die werden ja getötet durch das Chlor. Was heißt sofort? Wirklich innen instant. Aber so in einem schlecht chlorierten Whirlpool oder Naturteich können Spermien, würde ich sagen, jetzt gute zwei Stunden überleben. Aber die können da nicht einfach weiterleben wie Lebewesen in so einem Teich, oder? Oder noch länger wahrscheinlich. Nee, okay. Dass sie da einziehen. Nein, nein. Ich sage jetzt einfach selbstbewusst, was ich glaube, was die Antwort ist. Ja, G du, ja, Gepäck in der Hand, Köln, Wendlor-Strasse, Fahrrad. Abgegeben, genau, und dann kam irgendwann der Test zurück, ein PDF, wie man so funktioniert. Und da stand drin, Geruch, Doppelpunkt normal. Und da dachte ich mir, was sind die Abstufungen? Total, ich hätte da gerne so eine Liste an möglichen Auswahlmöglichkeiten gesehen und eins ist angekreuzt. Dann weißt du ja, okay, woran bin ich vorbeigestraft? Wir haben nämlich schon mal drüber geredet, über die Fehlergerüche und Aromen im Wein. Genau, ja, Fehlessenz. Stichwort Geruch fährt. Genau. Boah, Jesus Christ, da bist du ja in deinem Leben nicht mehr froh. Naja gut, du bist ein Hengst, da habe ich mir das schon erwartet.
Ja, jedenfalls habe ich mir vorgestellt,
da wahrscheinlich geht da jemand mit der Nase rein.
Das ist ja wirklich tatsächlich einfach eklig.
Und da kann man jetzt auch, da kommen ja Ärzte und Ärztinnen immer mit diesem, na ja,
das ist halt professionell und da ist auch kein Ekel
involviert und blablabla. Ihr seid doch auch Menschen.
Ja. Ihr seid keine Götter,
die Götter in Weiss. Ja, ja, ja.
Ihr seid auch Menschen, da riechen Menschen am Spermabehälter. ich würde es sogar andersrum sehen, wenn ich acht Jahre lang Medizin studieren muss und dann sagt mir, so hier ist eine Palette Becher schönen Nachmittag und du denkst, okay, dafür habe ich meine komplette Jugend geopfert für ein Einser-Abi und dann studiert in einer schmutzigen WG, wo mir Leute irgendein Bullshit erzählt haben für Zehennägel und das war's jetzt? Ey, wir brauchen endlich einen fucking Geruchsroboter. Sorry, aber woran forschen wir, wenn nicht an einem Geruchsroboter, der uns das mal hat?
Ich erinnere mich nämlich, dass mein Vater mir erzählt hat, weil er hat für eine Firma gearbeitet, die haben Abfüllmaschinen für Coca-Cola, Bierbrauereien etc. gemacht.
Also Abfüll- und Etikettiermaschinen für Coca-Cola, Bierbrauereien etc. gemacht. Also Abfüll- und Etikettiermaschinen. Und da geht es ja darum, die Mehrweg-Plastikflaschen von Coca-Cola sind immer die gleichen, diese dicken Flaschen, PET-Flaschen. Und da ist entweder Cola drin, Fanta Sprite oder halt Wasser. Bonacqua damals war dann so die Wasserlinie von Coca-Cola, das haben die ja wahrscheinlich andere, ich weiß nicht wie die heissen, und da wurde dann, hat die Firma entwickelt, eine Maschine, die war einzigartig damals, die riechen kann, ob in der Flasche vorher Coca-Cola oder ein anderer Softdrink drin war oder Wasser, weil wenn Coca-Cola drin war, konnte man danach kein Wasser reinfüllen, weil man hätte das nicht rausbekommen. Aber die werden ja schon rausgewaschen davor, oder? Natürlich, klar, aber Plastik ist ja jetzt auch keine Stahlwand. Plastik lebt, Plastik lebt, Plastik greift auf, Plastik ist ein Schwamm. Plastik hat ein Gedächtnis. Voll, und Plastik hat sich erinnert an Coca-Cola. Da kommt tatsächlich wieder Cola rein, aber ist nicht die Balance irgendwann total raus? Weil wenn du jetzt irgendwie so eine 100 Tonnen Mehrwegflaschen kriegst, dann kannst du ja nicht garantieren, dass das genau mit den Produktionsvorgaben, dann hast du plötzlich nur Zufall, nur Sprite und was ist da mit den anderen Produkten? Das ist ja ich glaube Cola und Sprite geht sogar zusammen, ich glaube nur Wasser, so wie Blutgruppen, wo du dann sagen kannst, die darf an die spenden und die, aber niemals Wasser in die Cola-Flasche. Aber Cola in Sprite. Ich glaube, das Cola ist das ekligste, ätzendste, ist wie eine Wandfarbe. Du kannst ja auch nicht eine schwarze Wand mit Weiss bemalen, wahrscheinlich, das ist zu dunkel. Du kannst es nicht komplett decken, also musst du es erst mal vorstreichen Weiss und noch mal Weiss drüber. Und ich glaube, Cola ist so endstufig. Ich glaube, du kannst in eine Spreitflasche kannst du Cola reinmachen, aber du kannst nicht von Cola zurück, jemals wieder. Das ist schon geil. Weiß ich nicht, alles erfunden. Aber diese Geruchsmaschine gab es und das ist ja genau das und ich hoffe, ich hoffe, dass diese Spermabecher von solchen Maschinen, die erkennen, ah, hier ist Ammoniak in der Luft. Hier ist Pferd am Start, ja. Genau, hier ist was drin, sie essen zu viel Snickers, hier ist was, ich spüre was, was nicht gesund ist, oder wenn nichts gespürt wird, ist es halt Geruch normal. Ich hoffe, es ist sowas, ich hoffe, es ist kein Mensch, der da rumriecht. Aber das ist ja total genial, dass die recycelt werden, dann kommt da das Gleiche nochmal rein. Das ist genial, ja. Inzwischen machen das wahrscheinlich viele, aber früher war das so ... Das heißt so eine Flasche, also die sagt, oh, jetzt bin ich eine Cola-Flasche, mal gucken, was ich im nächsten Leben werde. Ah, wieder Cola-Flasche, okay, mal gucken, was ich beim nächsten ... Ah, schon wieder Cola-Flasche. Mal schauen, was ich beim nächsten Mal bin. Ist das denn wie so die Hogwarts-Häuser, wo du einmal eine Entscheidung getroffen hast? Also wie werden die einsortiert, dass sie sagen, ich bin mein Leben lang Fanta-Flasche? spricht ja der entsprechende Hulm einfach so oder so unter dem arm einfach so gebt deinen arm hoch hier gar harry potter ja unter der robe ich habe mich vorher informiert und man muss es nicht machen und jeder der sich weigert kommt so auto und schaffepaft du weigerst dich ich habe nur gelesen man muss es nicht man muss es nicht die Robo hochheben, weil das ist ja gar nicht üblich hier in England, dass man immer die Robo hochheben muss.
Ich rieche alles auf Verlieren. Ich rieche alles. Fucking Hood, ey. Fucking Hood. Ich glaube jedenfalls, dass da unsere Regel eintritt, nämlich unsere Regel, sobald ein unerklärliches technisches Achievement vorliegt, sind es eigentlich tausend Inder.
Ja.
Und ich glaube, da riechen Inder an Flaschen. Aber es gibt ja kein Fernriechen, also du kannst ja nicht sagen, riechen wir das mal aus Mumbai, sondern klar, du kannst visuell wie mit dem Einkauf. Ja, der alte Gag, es gibt kein Geruchsfernsehen. Ja, aber es gibt ja kein Fernriechen, dass du sagst, ah, jemand auf der anderen Seite der Welt, ja, ja, noch nicht, noch nicht. Vielleicht zur Veröffentlichung der Folge gibt es das schon, vielleicht wird diese Folge fünf Minuten veröffentlichen. Denn wie gesagt, wir nehmen sieben Jahre im Voraus inzwischen auf. Richtig. Wir nehmen so viel auf, dass wir uns dann in Ruhe einfrieren lassen können und ihnen das nicht merkt. Genau. Ja. Dann liebe Grüße von Stefan Tietze. Ja, und zurück.
Und alles Gute für die nächste Woche.
Ansonsten hören wir uns, wenn es wieder heisst.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Alles Gute zum Urstag an Bianca und Sina und Martin.
Macht's gut, feiert schön und vielen Dank für die Eier.
Liebe Grüße, haut rein.
Tschüss, macht's gut, liebe Gruss.
This has indeed been a worst birth product. Haut rein! Tschüss, macht's gut, lieben Gruss!